- Je suis très heureux de vous rencontrer,
d'échanger avec vous et d'écouter vos suggestions.
Avec eux, Monsieur Gao va jouer sur la fibre patriotique.
Nous allons construire une ville industrielle qui va couvrir
plus de 70 kilomètres carrés.
Ici, il n'y a jamais eu aucun plan de cette ampleur.
Les petites maisons en bois des agriculteurs sont très simples
à déplacer.
Si le projet est approuvé par le gouvernement,
il y aura un énorme changement ici dans 15 ou 20 ans.
Ça deviendra une ville de premier rang en Afrique,
car elle aura été construite par la Chine.
Et l'espace pour son business, Monsieur Giao ne cesse de l'agrandir.
Il a réussi à convaincre les autorités éthiopiennes
de lui céder du terrain pour sa zone industrielle.
- La plupart des entreprises chinoises font des profits ici.
Et du coup, le gouvernement est bien au fait des bénéfices
sous forme d'impôts ou d'emplois pour la population.
C'est gagnant gagnant.
Voilà. Regardez, de ce côté, c'est la deuxième phase.
On attend cette terre.
De l'autre côté de cette barrière, monsieur Giao ne voit pas
les grands perdants de l'opération.
Les agriculteurs de la région, comme Marrou,
il a été exproprié de ses terres pour faire place
à la zone industrielle.
Bientôt, tous ces champs vont être recouverts d'usines.
- Avant, on mangeait cette terre.
On en bénéficiait.
C'était notre pain quotidien.
On ne possédait rien,
mais on buvait de l'eau et on se nourrissait des produits
de notre terre. Maintenant, on a plus rien.
Marrou a été indemnisé 20 centimes d'euro le mètre carré,
soit 6000 euros pour ces 3 hectares.
Une belle somme vite épuisé puisqu'il a perdu son outil de travail.
À 58 ans, tout ce qu'il lui reste, c'est cette petite maison
et quelques bêtes qui n'ont nulle part où aller paître.
Il est maintenant obligé d'acheter de quoi les nourrir.
- Voilà, ce sont mes bêtes, elles sont toujours enfermées ici.
Voilà tout ce que j'ai.
Tout ça, je vous le montre pour vous faire comprendre
les conséquences de ce qui est arrivé.
Maintenant, il n'y a plus rien.
Je reste à la maison. C'est tout.
Le fermier a eu sept enfants avec sa femme.
Ils ont toujours veillé à ce qu'il reçoive une bonne éducation.
Tout ça, ce sont mes filles. Elles ont toutes fait des études
et elles aussi. Et elle aussi, elle a fait des études.
Mais malgré son diplôme, la cadette n'a trouvé qu'un travail
à l'usine, précaire et mal payé.
L'argent qu'elle gagne, ce n'est même pas suffisant
pour s'acheter des vêtements.
C'est nous qui la nourrissons et qui la logeons.
Ce qu'ils produisent dans ces usines, on n'en voit pas la couleur.
Ça ne sert pas à la communauté.
Tous ces objets partent à l'étranger.
Avant, nous n'avions pas besoin d'argent.
On avait déjà tout, des vaches, le beurre, le lait, les céréales.